[موسيقى]
اعتقد بان الاجابه عن هذا السؤال صعب جدا
فليس واضحا
الى اين يتجه رئيس شيا فيما يخص
دفعه
صعود الصين او الى ماذا اي مدى يرغب
بالوصول اليه
فقد
تنعى عن سياساتي
والتي تمثلت بتجنب النزاعات والتركيز على
النمو الاقتصادي وهذا الرئيس الصيني اقصد
شي لا يتجنب النزاعات والمواجهات على
الاقل الكلاميه
وكما ان نسب النمو قد تضاعف تفاهه يواجه
اوضى عنه حيث الشعبيته بدات بالانخفاض
وبشكل سريع
والاقتصاده لن ينمو بنفس السرعه التي نما
عليها خلال 20 عاما الماضيه
[موسيقى]
سلوكياته في نفسي الوقت سلوكيات الصين
بشكل عام توحد الدول ضده
فهل سيستمر في هذا الطريق ام
[موسيقى]
حل السياره اي مصلحه في
الضغطي مثلا لاعاده التوحيدي تايوان او
ضميه تايوان ام هل سيعودون الى سياسات
الرؤساء السابقين للصين الذين مثلوا
تحديات اقل العالم وهذا ما ادرا بفائده
كبيره للصين على الاقل وعلى الصعيد
الاقتصادي لا اعرف الاجابه عن هذه الاسئله
ولكن اعرفه بان سياسته
موجهه تجاه التشجيع على ذلك
وبالتاكيد هنالك ايضا مستوى من او البعض
قلقون اكثر مني فيما يخص الصين
[موسيقى]